the Cloverfield paradox has a relatively
simple plot a Space Station crew is
tasked with activating a particle
accelerator called the shepherd which
will create a clean and renewable source
of energy for a resource deprived earth
things start to get complicated however
when the machine creates a rift in
space-time propelling the crew into a
parallel dimension little do they know
this also sets into motion the events of
the first and second Cloverfield movies
so how does the movie get from a simple
energy experiment story to an all-out
monster invasion movie let's walk
through the last bits of the Cloverfield
paradox and break it down monster
madness Cloverfield fans have long
speculated about where the monsters from
the first movie came from but paradox
finally offers a definitive answer they
came from another dimension oddly enough
we find this out thanks to an onscreen
interview with the conspiracy theorist
who warns the world that launching the
Sheppard could have devastating
consequences his words are unfortunately
ignored of course but he's ultimately
proven right once an overload of the
Sheppard system thrust the crew into an
alternate reality while introducing
untold numbers of Hell beasts to run
roughshod over earth the film's closing
moments revealed that by 2028 there's
been a full-on invasion of monsters all
over the planet you'll having to come
back to these things judging from the
size of the one we do see pop through
the clouds in the last shot if there is
a significant number of these things
roaming about the place humans don't
stand a chance world war what before the
extra dimensional chaos breaks out it's
very clear that earthlings are already
having a lot of trouble sustaining their
way of life
a global energy crisis has put several
nations Germany and Russia in particular
at the brink of war and that sense of
desperation and paranoia trickles into
the dynamics of the International Space
Station's crew which features both a
German and a Russian scientist working
on different aspects of the mission
joinha wall may 18th but to the little
children boyfriend over here I do once
we journey with the crew to the parallel
dimension we discover that on that earth
war has already broken out and that
timeline Schmitt actually was a German
agent who'd been sabotaging their
mission to stoke the flames of war so
chances are
if the monsters hadn't shown up the
human race might have gone over the edge
all by itself anyway the god particle
like its franchise predecessor 10
Cloverfield Lane the Cloverfield paradox
was written as an entirely separate
project at first Lane was based on a
script called the cellar while paradox
was developed as the god particle for
reasons that aren't altogether clear
from the movie itself in scientific
terms a god particle is a name for what
is properly called
a Higgs boson a particle effectively
responsible for the origin of mass
they're also theorized to have the
ability to overlap and occupy the same
points in space-time
unlike other particles like electrons of
protons in theory god particles may have
played a part in the fictional function
of the Shepard particle accelerator in
earlier cuts of the film or perhaps it
just served as a cool title to a weird
sci-fi movie that dabbled in particle
physics but either way there aren't any
God particles in the Cloverfield paradox
so it's a good thing they change the
name one world saved it's easy to chalk
up the efforts of the film's protagonist
to a zero-sum game they go through all
of the effort to get back to their home
dimension and figure out how to make the
particle accelerator work only to
realize as soon as they do that earth is
now facing a problem the accelerator
can't fix it's a bitter twist
but there is one silver lining the crew
does save earth it's just not bare earth
right before activating the accelerator
and heading back to their earth during
the film's climax Hamilton and Schmitt
send the schematics for the Sheppard
particle accelerator to the parallel
earth the one at war over energy
resources it might take some time but
this planet now has the means to access
clean renewable energy and save itself
hopefully without inviting a bunch of
massive monsters into this dimension
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]